welcome Anya hey guys how are you great
[Laughter]
of course thanks for your big fan thanks
for being shave I'm sorry I liked it I
mean it looks rugged an old Manish yeah
I like that to be an older gentleman I
was I don't like younger but I was much
older how old 60 was like a young 60
like I told a few people about him and
they're like he's 60 like they've known
who he is I thought he was like 50 70 60
seems like 50 he said I know it ended
after two months it really took me by
surprise why the prostate issues what
happened
I dropped my change in his bedpan no
what how come have what happened with
you in the old fellow is it sexy when
he's on top of you and there's like a
life alert hanging somebody where it's
the pros outweigh the cons they're all
pros so much that you're like I could I
could settle yeah and you catch yourself
settling right and you don't realize the
cons are like the cons like these these
are the things that I always say never
never but there's so many great pros
this isn't that big of a deal was fine
he's rich he's got ambition he makes
cool stuff he's creative you got got a
cute look a cute style and he's 60 so
he's not gonna be that difficult to keep
track of no they could be your daddy
put me on his knee so what was it was it
just that the first time yes see I got
did the cons just start to catch up and
you win oh no now it's been two months
the pros are starting to use their lose
their luster and the cons are starting
to shine through what was it cars one
main con which was okay so I've never
dated a Jewish guy and I think this is
equality the whole thing with Christ I
am a Russian Jew I think because my mom
is it's all through the matrilineal line
right anyway I felt this kinship with
him he's Jewish anyway we'd be making
out and he'd do this very woody al
anything we're like mid make out he'd
just be like okay hold on I just I feel
like this is going too fast and I was
like why are you kissing yeah like if it
was getting into you know they'd never
take you out of the moment yes
eventually we did and then he would
continue doing this thing where he would
stop and be like I just you know I'm
super into you I'm falling in love with
you and you know I'm your boyfriend
you're my girlfriend but you know I'm
still very ambivalent about how serious
this should be now that's weird what
what the was it anything weird that got
him off like could he only get an
erection if you fished into his pocket
and pulled out like a piece of candy
I'll tell you what I was looking for
stuff like that because we were having
some issues Bharath huh yeah during
intercourse yeah and the one thing that
was started making me angry was he
wouldn't acknowledge it oh no just
wouldn't acknowledge it just keep
pumping away while the shaft accordions
against the outside of the vagina or
just like I would love it if he just had
said like hey I realized like something
you know what do you do try to make eye
contact and like with eyes that I know
that I just do a big eye roll have to
acknowledge Italy it's happened to me so
I look down I'm a guy for pete's sake
the little fellas taking a break
dad it's like we're all human we have on
days in our off days like I would it's
just like a well if you went down on a
woman and she's like on her second day
of her cycle you'd be annoyed like oh
you could have told me I mean the heads
up on that absolutely I'd say that too I
was put her clothes back on showing her
the front door trying to stick it in and
then it wouldn't go it was you just keep
rubbing the header or we be fooling
around and like it would just be not not
active clearly did he ever justify it no
did you turn him on like it was it that
maybe he liked you but he has the whole
lustin and love thing I did say like are
you into this cuz and he was a yes I'm
so into you and I was like okay okay cuz
it you know and that was like what are
you into
porn-wise and he's like I don't know you
well enough to to tell you that you know
I don't know you I would I would have
[ __ ] told you before you came over
here here's what I'm thinking and this
happens I think sometimes they you date
somebody who's older right and then you
go yeah but they act young yes and you
don't realize that that means they're
immature and stunted exactly and you get
to this place where you're like this
person couldn't hang out with other
people his age cuz they'd be like what
he's like developmentally disabled
what's wrong with this person I should
have talked to you but you had sex with
you yes so what what what was there
anything to uh talking jury like what
finally got his dick I finally this one
night I was like come on you gotta watch
porn he's like no I don't I don't wanna
I was like you don't know me well enough
we know everything we've been like
facetiming three hours a day we talk all
the time we know each other pretty well
and also I don't judge that like at all
everybody watches porn like I'm asking
you yeah I'm like no judgement zone go
for it and he was like I and then he
finally told me a little thing I said it
was nothing big and then I would I sort
of started role-playing and Bing I don't
know the guys really it was nothing
excited it was just like I can't even
honestly remember like submissive or
something submissive no like he liked
that to be submissive or for you to be
me I guess oh he's very insecure about
it
yeah like very judgmental and then but
we did it was great a sort of that night
there was still technically but rope
around your bosoms many levels have that
kind of equipment well how would you
feel if your like just tell me what
you're into just he's like okay you know
sometimes I do like a little submission
you're like okay and he's like you know
I like to tie up the titties wait I like
to tie a girl like like you're a naughty
girl and I'm your teacher okay and I
like to hold your mouth open with a
speculum and [ __ ] you know Dennis Rader
[Laughter]
okay so he still couldn't get a rod he
lost it yeah and then I started thinking
maybe it is an age thing he takes a
Viagra but the [ __ ] I start I was about
to suggest that but then we broke up
because of the ambivalence thing he kept
and every day he would be more into me
than any guy I've ever dated on the
outside on paper like out in public all
over me almost - all over me like he
would lean oh I don't like do this like
deep tongue then I was like easy like
we're in a bistro in the West Village
how could you want to shove your tongue
down my throat here if you can't even
maintain an erection
a little bit of a nerd and was Mike
didn't realize what he was doing I kind
of had to teach him a little sure and
then there's a late-bloomer he just kind
of started like noticing girls at 54
people are kind of kids ever married no
married yes no kids he's gay maybe yeah
he told me that a girlfriend and it
asked him if he was gay oh boy I I was
like he's a little femme but like I spy
the porn he watches that he couldn't so
he could have what would what would
sound like a real guy thing to say to a
girl I like dominant I think he's really
repressed about his desires and yeah
cause it's dudes and maybe he does like
I think he liked a different type of
girl he was always talking about this
one girl that was his friend who was
I can act like a an addict and I'm like
oh you need to rescue somebody he was
always like I love her she's she's got a
lot of problems and I want to give her
money and she's my bet one of my best
friends and like you're in love with her
maybe he's a pay Pig
you know maybe he gets off on just
helping people and giving him money and
yeah we had a dominatrix in here once
that said she had a like a client that
all he did they never even had sex all
he did was give her money like if it
were raining outside she would make him
drive to an ATM hmm get out of the car
in the rain run across the street take
the max out of his account and just hand
it to her and that would be it that's
what got him off that was such a strange
thing yeah really bad its power and and
you know just interested in you and
ignores you yeah I think that is what I
think that might have been his thing I
don't know whatever it was we didn't
work out and I wish I would have
listened hydrati how did I end it
we just every day it started to get
weird and he wouldn't he stopped having
sex and I was like what's going on how
does that stop what it like I don't even
feel that's two months there's only two
months and I was like we've only had sex
like five times in two months and then
it's petering we were oh I know it it
was we had this Sunday afternoon he's a
very busy guy works like every day like
you guys kind of a workaholic but he's
into his job and I was into his stuff
and then what type of thing does he do
he likes to put a shoelace through a
keyhole to LaGuardia he's like I want to
see you right away for lunch we go to
lunch and I say I got a mean Nikki
Glaser for dinner like 7:00 so we have
from 2:00 to 7:00 to hang he's like
great at 4:30 we're walking around West
Elm or something looking at furniture
stuff and I go I wish I could like make
out with me on this couch and he goes
I'll make out with you at my house and I
go great so we go back to his house he
throws me on the bed we make out and
it's getting to the point where it's
getting very heated oh yeah to the point
where you're like oh we're definitely
gonna have sex right it's past the point
of makeout right and we got no place to
be
yeah and it's debt and I'm like I'm 19
9 percent sure we're going to have sex
and then he goes okay you better go I
gotta go to work and I was like I
thought for sure he was joking and I
never get I finally understand blue
balls yeah it was it wasn't that I like
needed to get off I felt like duped or
something like right you're [ __ ] with
me no no no he wants to want to [ __ ] you
like he wants to want that and he
convinces himself ok and then he gets
into his head and he knows his dick
isn't gonna work because it's not what
he really wants but it's nothing
personal against you you're beautiful
and he really likes you but it's just he
can't get that desire up but it's
something to do with by a person it's
probably either he wants something that
you don't have what you might be a dick
or a kink that you can't provide or to
rescue you know you said there's
something like I think I needed you're
right the rescuing thing or I need a
penis so let's figure that one out yeah
this is great
alright I'm done I've done it I hope for
his sake that he finds some dude that
needs rescuing and then he can just be
buddies with you like he wants to be
like I'm sure he really likes you as a
person we were great buddies and I think
we will be again and I remember when I
was crying over the break-up because our
final conversation was I cooked him
dinner and then I accidentally burnt the
salmon I made some miso glazed salmon it
burned in the broiler and he was like it
looks delicious I'm like it looks like
[ __ ] it's like black and he goes no it's
great and we ate it and we had this nice
night and then we crawled it in my bed
and he promptly went to sleep and I was
like come on are we really
you're not gonna again like Sunday that
was Sunday that he sent me home because
he had to work and then Monday I cooked
him dinner and he was like I just don't
want to you know I'm not emotionally
there yet with you and I'm like it's not
about emotion love to me last night and
oh come on and I'm like it's not like I
need he's like you're really making this
about the sex I'm like it's not it's
that there's some intimacy thing they
were small dick anyway so I really
enjoyed his present wonderful person
yeah yeah a little decadent didn't work
as well and he's insecure about the ism
we're
so what you might want to put it
someplace else sometimes you like
somebody as a per as a man sometimes you
like a beautiful woman but you don't
want to [ __ ] her and there's nothing to
do with her it's just it's something is
off and you feel weird about that as a
guy you try to force yourself to want it
it's possible to just have that like
infatuation and then realize like oh
this is a personality thing this isn't
physical yeah this is a yeah like we we
our minds meld but our bodies are like I
wish I could tell you guys this off the
air but um go ahead is my body as your
body ever just like physically recoiled
that's quite a coil I like couldn't
there's a guy you like the way his balls
smell she was disgusted a great person
I really sure sure sure what happened
what made you require chemically totally
involuntary and I actually enjoy giving
[ __ ] when I love someone and I felt
like I was falling for this person and
then and he knew he was like there's no
way you could be gagging on that so he
was you know like it it worked
eventually the way you were going down
on at this point way too much hair for
20/20 54 so what happened what made you
recoil was the smell I don't even know I
think it was yeah maybe I there in the
moment I'm like why am I doing this why
am i gagging there's you know there's
your body telling your brain you're not
in the right space right there shouldn't
be was it with your nose touch his balls
is that it wasn't even like I can't put
my finger on anything I think maybe it's
pheromones or something I can't quite
name it was a taste I didn't it was
sweaty was a long day at the office
matter that comes out Oh lady okay
I'm trying to be dignified matter - no
the [ __ ] didn't taste it taste it it was
a curdled when is when is he when his
man matter was released when his man
matter what somebody like really loved
them it doesn't matter yeah but this
mattered yeah the lust that's all not
that I loved him like intellectually and
when we broke up the final day I was
like look I'm into this you seem to be
super into me I've never had anyone
court me like this like winding me and
dining me and you tell me you love me
and you're my boyfriend and you've
introduced me to all of your friends
like stuff other guys I've dated I've
never done and yet every other date you
say you're ambivalent or you don't want
to sleep with me so look I'm in right
and Yuki kept saying like I feel like we
have to have the rest of our lives for
good I'm like I don't know if I'll be
with you next month but I'm into it
today and no man thinks that way when it
comes to sex
no man thinks well we're not close
enough he's 60 was that how much how
much times you have to have to figure
out he's gotta be yeah I think because I
said you know I don't sleep with guys
that are my boyfriend I said that in
like week four and he was like okay okay
and that kind of freaked him out he's
like so then we can't sleep together
unless you know I really know for sure
this guy had just gotten out of him a
very long marriage so I think he was
much younger yeah yeah like you're too
young for what I was looking for him
like thanks to like he's all she's
younger and hot and intimidating and
like you know to him he's probably go
I'm not gonna [ __ ] her right yeah and
all that any of any kind of
self-fulfilling yeah and then he did not
know he definitely he was correct
out of nowhere he goes well I'm just not
ready for a relationship then and I was
like all right which way he ended up
breaking up with you I said look I'm in
and you keep being ambivalent and saying
you one more time but like we're not
working so you let him to the water and
he drank yes when was this that was I
would say like three months ago Oh ever
since maybe two months ago we broke up
yeah we met once and that was great all
my friends all my girlfriends oh you
should not meet him what are you doing
I reached out to him because I had some
I was like maybe I was too pushy
and I'd like pushed him too much cuz I
was like I just kept thinking about how
our last conversation he said just give
me a few more weeks I'm just emotionally
all true in my head and I thought I'll
just reach out to him say look if you
really needed more time I'm I enjoyed
you I loved what we had and if you want
more time to date me I'll be patient you
don't have to be my it went on to like
make this a big commitment you know
right and then he goes let's meet if we
met and do you ever have that
perspective where you see somebody and
you're like that's who I love yep I saw
him from afar and I was like oh I've
been in relation the same didn't feel
the same he wore these shoes that I told
him on one date I was like I love your
style
I hate those shoes though what's wrong
with them they were like women's running
shoes like mesh they were didn't like
his track mesh shoes he's probably but
he's like 64 shoes on a guy probably
thought they were cool yes uses them to
run away from sex and I remember on that
date where I was I hate those shoes but
yeah yeah we were joking around and he
he goes you'll never see these shoes
again oh really anyone ever again
and he didn't mind that I brought that
up but on this date or when we reunited
he wore the shoes and I was like oh this
is not good that's his way of saying hey
I control what's on my feet yeah I have
the power back but you're feeling
changed see you didn't start getting
jealous I'm just thinking like you'd be
out on a Friday and go like right now
he's probably trying to mush his penis I
did have moments like that the first two
weeks I was a little I cried so much
really and yeah it was very odd cuz he
was I don't know if it's I wouldn't say
sociopathic he's very charming and it's
part of his job to be super interested
in people he's like you guys like you
girls are good at drawing people out
there's Clint according to the apps team
reports Bill Clinton may not have such a
problem with younger women no
it's not an issue do you know what it is
I'm sure he's a good egg but he's like
he's we've all done it every man has
done it where you're just you you don't
want the sex with a person as much as
you think you're supposed to and you try
to force it that's all it's another it
wasn't it isn't it is weird when you
have that moment though that the
feelings have just completely changed
and you don't realize it until like you
see the person you're like I don't have
any feelings for you at all I don't know
how this happened it's weird he had I
remember his eyes looked like black like
he hated me there was this weird thing
like he was just like oh look cuz every
time we showed up on a date he'd be like
he'd like spin me around he'd be like
thrilled to be with me touching me all
the time I was just like this is crazy I
usually date these aloof kind of like
sullen musician guys they're like mmm
it's all about me and my career this guy
was just like I can't believe I'm with
you you're like this cute blonde girl
and what kind of bothered me you're like
this heteronormative blonde girl I can't
believe I'm with you I'm like first of
all that's nice but like I'm not I'm
like the quirky blonde girl he's like no
you're the leading lady I'm like no I'm
not I made me feel kind of basic yes
yeah but yeah our last meeting I
remember he goes so I wanted to talk to
you about your email um he said if I
needed more time
you would give it to me and I don't
actually want to date you
I don't either I thought that we knew
that's why we weren't hanging out yeah I
guess he wanted to tell me I was too
hard on myself he probably thought you
were just away pining for him did he say
why I said why and leading up to this my
therapist is like this guy has no
answers for anything has answered it
everything is I don't know he never
gives you a straight answer so I asked
him what helped you arrive at that
decision that you don't want to date me
anymore and he goes oh this is gonna be
so sad to say to someone you date but
since you asked I'll tell you I just
want something
else I go that's not an answer that's
like so vague I guess that's not like he
was trying to force himself to feel a
certain way yeah and your dick is
basically your dick tells the truth yes
like you dick says no don't take out
your emotional problems on me [ __ ] be
honest with what you want that's all it
is it's true so does your puss yeah that
was right sometimes that little fella
dries up bodies yeah yeah I've been in
relationships before where they've been
like 3-month relationships and I'll just
wake up one morning and we'll be like
totally in love you'd be like I like
dicks
that's not sure that's not even need
that
soundbite quite frankly it's there's no
application for it but I just wake up
and I'm like I don't feel anything for
you anymore
yep you know what I mean it's just a run
a marriage just like it's just what do
you ascribe that to what do you
attribute that I don't know I feel like
I come out of a fog where it's like that
sort of knew like oh this is so much fun
and you're so great and blah blah blah
and then you kind of come out of it and
you realize like it was almost amania
and you don't have much in common and
this person is actually kind of annoying
and yeah there's nothing about you I
don't dislike you but there's just
nothing it's like what's left and I keep
using the word what's left to get the
dopamine going like when you're trying
to court somebody or get something
there's always something to get the next
hi yeah okay there's always this thing
we'll do this for the first time we'll
do that for the first time and then once
you've done those things that's just
okay now it's here you realize that
there's nothing it was all about just
getting that next drug right you'd
always start it always starts with two
like oh my god I think this is actually
gonna happen I can't believe this is
happening
I never would have thought that me and
you oh this is so let's go do this let's
go do that and then one day it just
dries up and you go yeah I don't I don't
want to do normal stuff with you like I
don't want to just live life and hang
out with you they say if you can make it
it's interesting you said three months
cuz I just read this book and she was
saying you know the first three months
of the honeymoon phase in the next three
or the negotiation phase where it's like
alright do we want to do this how
are we gonna do our time like how much
time are we gonna spend together how
much playtime are we gonna have together
like all the sort of mundane [ __ ] oh
when you're figuring out what life is
gonna look like
yeah like reality and she says that you
have to have sexual chemistry you have
to have compatibility and you have to
have great communication and I think
with this guy we had incredible
communication a lot of compatibility and
no chemists very little physical
chemistry I've had a woman's vagina not
be wet and that's not a stretch and my
technique of of making it happen didn't
always work unfortunately
what was the what was the technique I
was just I was just kind of like Joker
nice little moistened is always male
like my [ __ ] is a fella yeah you're
right I did use male terminology which
is very telling so yeah you see you're
doing okay though finally I just thank
God man I don't know I think it's
there's something about pheromones they
stay in your system for a while too
oxytocin in women is so much higher than
in men once you have sex and then it
does Peter out after a couple months I
think right around the 8 week mark I was
like I'm fine so for those that don't
know onions a singer-songwriter I
respect this guy for coing they're
telling you in person yeah I just don't
want it I want something else I respect
that yeah any more shoes to let you know
this is for real
yeah there's still something really off
like he's trying to be a person like
he's crew that stole the whole thing is
like he's creating this image of what a
person is like he's not doing it because
he cares or he feels a certain way he's
doing it because that's what a person
should do yes yeah that's why when you
when you try to go any further there's
nothing there is
something robotic about him and when
I've spoken to a couple friends of mine
who have an autistic daughter they were
like he sounds super he sounds like he's
on the spectrum a little because that we
had a few moments where we'd be on a
date and then out of nowhere he do
something so socially inappropriate and
he wouldn't know it well first of all
I'm gonna remind me to tell you this
other thing out there I want to tell you
he would sit like I was sitting at
dinner and I said it's so fun to wear
high heels with you because I dated
somebody for like six years that hated
high heels he thought it looked [ __ ]
and so I didn't never wore high heels
and he liked me dressing in like
converse and like with pigtails
like a little little on the little girl
that room and this guy goes he didn't
like high heels and I go yeah I mean
it's just his preference you know I get
it people have a preference and then my
boyfriend said yeah I mean I've hated a
bunch of [ __ ] you've worn but you're
always really pretty and I was like okay
like what and it was like so out of left
field okay cool and he didn't laugh like
he didn't think it was funny
like if he would have laughed I might
have laughed but he was just like yeah
and I go like what he goes I don't know
I couldn't think of a thing I go well
you can't just say you hate my ass some
of my outfits because I dress up for you
you realize I'm like spending a lot of
time to look nice for you so give me an
example of a shirt or whatever that you
don't like I won't wear it again and he
goes I couldn't think of one I'm like I
just don't believe just that he thought
in that story head-on that night by the
way it's what he hated you think so he
didn't want to say it what you're
wearing right now yeah maybe you're
right
I mean just that he thought that the
point of that story was not that it's
weird that he hated high heels but that
he would say that he hated high heels
even though that he did it's just so
weird
backwards logic I didn't even know I
thought he was just like oh weird I like
high heels and he didn't yeah and then
he did another weird thing we were
kissing and we had gone to dinner at
this Mexican food place and we came home
and we're kissing in the doorway again
he was slightly robotic like you said
trying to act like a human like he was
he seemed like he was trying to make out
how they're supposed to make out right
not and I remember telling my friends
there's something not quite soulful
about him like he's going he doesn't he
doesn't kiss me in a soulful way he like
yeah like really our first kiss was
ramming my tongue down his tongue down
my throat and I was like whoa
so he's kissing me and then he goes hey
yeah like really making out and he pulls
back and goes hey you should brush your
teeth or something you should brush your
teeth or something the way his breath
was not a ten out of ten many times I
never would have said that you just
tolerate you know not everybody has like
minty fresh breath all the [ __ ] time
I think he might have been gay in on the
spectrum and I walk in there I'm like
I'll be right back I walk in the
bathroom I look at myself in the mirror
and I just go and then I brush my teeth
and I'm just like I can't figure out if
I'm ashamed of my breath or freaked out
that I'm dating this strange person that
just said [ __ ] Anya I think you might
have I think he's I think you might have
dated an old gay sociopath with
Asperger's in the middle of kissing he
just said you should brush your teeth or
something laughs like didn't think it
was odd also he is the caricature like
if you look in the dictionary for the
word quirky there's a picture of him
like he is quirky it's like he I dated
Woody Allen basically but I mean like
Woody Allen is clearly on the autism
spectrum yes right now is he woody I
don't know he might be I never said he
never struck me as I he's just a genius
and a weird comic genius but he never
struck me as autistic like you see he
has social grace I mean he knows when
he's in it being inappropriate away yeah
so went to a play we went to see this
play and the lead actresses husband was
I don't know ten seats away and this guy
that I was dating got like nice seats
every time for every thing so we'd be in
the second row around all these Broadway
producers and it's intermission and he
stands up and to everybody goes she's
terrible right she's horrible he goes
she's so wooden love this guy I'm
laughing I'm dying I'm like oh my god
you can't say this there's vendors right
there and he has absolutely zero idea
that he's being interpreted Asperger I
thought it was cute the whole time I'm
like he's so funny he's like really
ballsy he wasn't being ballsy he was
just like no she's bad I'm gonna tell
you something right now
that's Asperger if Jess ever gets hit by
a bus I'm gonna find a good woman on the
autism spectrum
just to have moments like that also if
he's listening again please change the
channel um I was at his apartment a tiny
one-bedroom I think he's a
multi-millionaire he lives in a teeny
tiny sort of dusty and dark one-bedroom
apartment and keeps all his money sure I
guess yeah I mean he my apartments nicer
and I'm not a multi-millionaire
songwriter so every we making out on the
couch and he's okay you dropped your
beverage I'm so sad that there was a top
on that bottle Jim yes just yesterday he
dropped an entire cup of cold brew on
the ground so it's one of our favorite
things to watch old man Jim fumble with
this thing that's a great photo shop
somebody did a chip in the [ __ ]
painting god damn that was good
amazing oh yes okay
so we'd be making out on the couch and
they'd be like hey I'll be right back I
need to walk to the bathroom and it's
dead quiet in his apartment wooden
floors and he walk in the bathroom close
the door I'm like I'm for sure being
Punk'd for sure I'm not even
exaggerating wouldn't he turned the
water on with the way to do it we've all
had it as a man is you turn the water on
high and you [ __ ] put your [ __ ]
over a towel how many times have you had
to fart into a towel
you spread your whole open so there can
just kind of clean fart and think you
couldn't hear and then he I like he
walked back in the room and I look at
I'm like okay and I'm and he just like
hey I'm just get right back on the couch
and I was like this is [ __ ] and
saying like for sure I'm being Punk'd
and yeah I think you need to find this
guy and see if maybe you can make it
work out after all the best I think he
should be in your life we love this yeah
yeah if anything he's not perfect but
he's a hero to us he is a limp dick I
thought I'm imagining things cuz I went
into the bathroom and then the floor I
hit a floorboard as I walked in and the
floor bar went and I go oh that kind of
sounds like his fart I think I think
he's just been stepping on floorboards a
lot right and then he came to my house
for dinner that night and I'll be right
back I went to the bathroom right after
him and there was no [ __ ] smell I the
toilet paper was still intact yeah so
he's just sitting on the toilet trying
to fart it's gotta relieve the pressure
Travis you like that saving all your
farts for the best just the visual in my
head was a movie Big Daddy yeah when
Sandy's ex starts dating the old man
imagine that old man going into the
bathroom and just farting there's so
much energy to this and didn't see any
red flags this is like you did you just
ignore them I wish I wish you would redo
the speech that Liv Tyler did and that
thing you do when she tells Jimmy how
many kisses she wasted on him but
somehow bring up the far truth
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app